it's one of the most remote regions in
the world
antarctica and has been coveted free
until now
the first cases of covet 19 were
reported earlier this week
at a chilean military research base
a pcr test show that 36 men tested
positive for kovid 19.
26 were army personnel and 10 were
civilians from a contractor company
who were doing scheduled maintenance
work at the antarctica base
the bernardo ojigins ricalme bay is
located in the chilean sector of
antarctica
it is one of the 13 bases chile operates
on the white continent
we know the exposure there is extreme it
can have a physiological effect on
people because of isolation
and changes in light several components
that can act as immunosuppressant
because of the work they do there
the 36 men are reportedly healthy but
under quarantine in the southern chilean
city of pundarena
but covet 19 continues to spread
elsewhere in latin america
increasing pressure on governments to
find medicines and vaccines fast
chile announced it will start
vaccinations next week
mexico and argentina in the next few
days
most countries in the region will begin
with a pfizer vaccine
but argentina has other plans for now
there's lots of anxiety among latin
american government to start
vaccinating the population as soon as
possible because there's fears of a
second wave early
in 2021 argentina's government for
example announced
that russia's sputnik vaccine is
expected in the next few days and that
a vaccination campaign is expected to
begin as soon
as local health entities authorize it
argentina signed a deal for 10 million
doses with russia
but there's very little information yet
about sputnik's efficacy and possible
side effects
so many people are skeptical about
taking it
there's not a lot of information on the
russian vaccine we don't know if they
had 11
000 tests 12 000 argentine authorities
may have a report but we haven't seen it
it's probably okay but the government
has failed to communicate that
effectively
covert 19 has had devastating effects in
latin america's economies and health
care systems
it has now reached what many call the
end of the world
as the virus continues to spread a
vaccine
is the one chance governments have to
make it stop
teresabo al jazeera buenos aires